kanye west sentimentalement toujours
pareil parce que moi je vous le dis j'ai
tous mes amis
oui qui m'appellent et qui me disent
christine kelly me plaît grandement et
j'ai beaucoup d'amis célibataire il ne
demande qu'une chose vous rencontrer
quelle est la madeleine démarche à
suivre
berne où rien ne vous inquiétez pas
banal venir dans un instant il y aura
des bonnes vannes
merci oui photo raymond blais cm c'est
mieux en passant par vous bien c'est
vrai voudriez c'est qu'on est fils
d'ouvrier alors intelligent généreux
sympa jésus fait débat mais c'est tout
vous basse et nathan généreux s'est
donnée montant de sa jeune blond vieux
jeu mais ça n'a même pas du tout on s'en
fout généreux non non ce à quoi les gens
j'ai l'héroïne de l'âge enfin
logiquement h à 18 h on a six et s il
aimait les femmes non non non pas du
tout c'est mon père alors aux abymes
juin monnaie elle va voler je vous dis
vous vous êtes viré
d'accord mais dès que tu diriges vous
drague
non mais calmez vous faire ça ne va vers
ça
téléspectateurs de choses alan ball look
trois jours ensemble et on a été sages
comme des images sera jamais la vérité
ait au caire rapportent tous les soirs
le 1 je vous lis ouais bah oui et au
bout d'un moment
non non je me suis rendu compte que
c'était juste un gars de l'hôtel que non
mais dans l'avion on s'est beaucoup
rapprochée s'est beaucoup rapproché amir
calme en évidence je connais tous ces
mecs je connais tous ouais jamais été un
long courrier d'avoir loupé éviter tous
ces mecs et one c'était une valve
oui vivement belle fille arrive qu'on
fasse une joute en raccord